let's think some more about the size and
shape of the viewport think about the
way you use devices phones and tablets
are often used in portrait orientation
whereas a full screen browser window on
a laptop is landscape now even though
you can't change the window size on a
phone or tablet these devices have
another rather tricky feature when it
comes to responsive
resizing orientation can change and when
it comes to landscape and portrait you
need to think about content as well as
size - all those square images can work
well in portrait mode on a phone but
wide images can be a real problem again
for responsive design the golden rule is
don't assume the viewport size will
always stay the same you'll learn the
impact of image choice and art direction
later in the course when you find out
how to use the picture element and later
in this lesson we'll look at ways to
work with orientation using media
queries